oh god what are you doing I can't
breathe I can't breathe pizza pasta of
course what are you serious pizza is
like the definition of fast food me no
don't put in a ravine don't throw
intervene at on camera don't throw to me
know jeez the way okay we're gonna go go
go go go up to the new place good
morning good morning good morning good
morning good morning it is now 643 in
the morning i got up at five something
new now have I even worst night
allergies we're packing up is an
exciting day we spent all yesterday
cleaning up because the guys who bought
the place from took forever to leave so
we were cleaning it up as they were
leaving super awkward anyway time to
pack up and go to the new place that's
what's up so my first step is trying to
disassemble the bed this is the most
complex bed I've ever had if you don't
really keep track and take pictures
every step along the way it's impossible
to back together again so I got my
camera in their kind of dissimilar bed
so it doesn't look like any of our drill
bits will fit so it means I have to do
it by hand it's give me a lot of work
this is a super helpful tool to help you
find the right key well half of them are
gone this side is good this side of
nothing this will not work next solution
round two
oh so the last couple pounds you move we
did it with our friends and this year we
decided hi we're gonna have somebody
look easier yeah all right back to work
so much easier with a drill did you
moving actual I time is our goal oh my
didn't be able to do naina didn't you uh
you haven't really fully moved out till
the computers gone so that's the next
project for me alex from tds wrote
amazing how's the move going rocking it
no more computer now so it's official
goodbye sweet office I loved you I
missed you so Nina's getting angry I
need some coffee and breakfast too it's
a like ten o'clock or something like
that we've been working working working
and I going to go to tim hortons do a
run get some coffee anything else you
can ask if they want Jordan's gonna go
change copy some of that ice cap that
you good some guys cap the ice cap see
you soon we've got a feast I got our
four ice caps the coffee breakfast is in
here and then underneath is another
dozen donuts yeah me donuts name is
saying something what do you say
oh yeah hey we got a lot of stuff Nina
mark said last week that we needed to
get Nina more stop you need more step it
knee may need some more stuff thanks
thanks mark thank you and now I'm
looking at this truck we don't need more
snack you may just need more staff unit
needs less that which of these yummy
donuts do I want to try I'm a sucker for
the maple cream okay okay everything's
all packed up and ready to go goodbye
house I have to do this well if you
think is going to this well for how long
were you for B and a half even talk
about it yeah good memories good times
huh new beginnings in adventures here we
go the truck is leaving without us Nina
we gotta hustle Oh what oh what are the
shampoo what happened it's Billy yeah
did he get any of my stuff oh it's on
the seat that's embarrassing it makes
you have sparkly hair so it'll be a
sparkly car no don't put it in a ravine
they'll tow intravenous on camera don't
throw a nervy no she's the way okay
we're gonna go go go good you go out to
the new please look at this big truck in
front of us holy cow what do they think
they are oh wait that's our truck let's
follow that truck
right we made it time to get the
elevator go see the concierge the
elevator on service and moving oh it's
already set up for us
there is all spanking brand-new very
exciting so even though we took
possession yesterday the old owners
didn't move out so we spent all
yesterday starting to clean up while
waiting for them to finish pooping their
stuff they still have some things in
here that he's going to come pick up
today at noon Nina made it it's our
first day can it it's very exciting
quick update we're about halfway through
no I'm not halfway through we've got
some stuff here we've got a special
creature right there the office is
starting to come together some of the
stuff interesting Nina had a donut the
breakfast now I got you breakfast you
didn't eat your breakfast I don't need
the donut your eat your sandwich oh yeah
so none of the moving guys like donuts
it's crazy never met moving guys I
didn't like donuts honey so but they
wanted ice caps its way sort of
different it's sweet drink they'll have
sweet drinks and that's sweet does that
make sense I want to know if that makes
sense leave it in the comments do you
like sweet drinks but not sweet food
does that make sense Nina says it's a
Chinese thing I don't know somebody
explained it to me he was very focused
what you're doing she's very focused
watching her Chinese videos oh holy cow
I'll be back I'm gonna get some water
I'm back I got the water donut still
have not been touched Nina you got to
sell the donuts a little more stuff
happening here slowly we gotta catch
coming in more boxes
it's happening another massive advantage
of a condo that I just realize is that
Nina can have a shower and then I can
have a shower and then we'll still be
hot water left for me condo living what
do you think you know what I don't like
this laughs well it's so close to the
top we can't get one of the big taps I
want to I want you to start a future
water thing Oh last time we put it on
the thing here it looks get on it now
it's our place it's nice to have if you
do water yeah okay I don't know how to
do that you gotta cut a hole in the
marble yeah really granular someone
won't do it really well if we had if we
get those professional ones they have to
do hmm that's nice I feel like I'm gonna
hit my head on this thing as I walk in I
want one of those big tab well I don't
know how you walk in my fish let's see
Gemma huh listen what I have a bigger
upper body I her bigger head I don't
know let's see whose head is bigger
let's do a head comparison at the head
this is bigger here he's holding what
are you doing I can't breathe I can't
breathe this is Nina's breakfast
sandwich and that's her doughnut you're
gonna wash this top wash what's this
nuisance yeah you just watch them though
yeah
no I want to get the office set up well
you know what uh-huh no why not you know
what happens when Evan gets his mind
doesn't view around you hey listen what
but would you say this one did you stop
what you can say it's not all about you
I thought all about me no I thought
about me but just feel like I feel like
if Evan does the thing if he likes it's
better for everybody because otherwise
i'm just going to be distracted and
think I need to go through my think it's
all obvious when you want is something
as always we always have it do it now
nah ah that was nasty I'm going to
arrange my office but before I can do
that we need music album but is some
good office arrangement theme music
Louie wants to set up a gaming station
here gaming house to have computers
there I can stand up there and I have
some stuff here and a bookcase here some
fun if we're gonna make it Fame there's
no space I gotta go get Alex I gotta get
Alex you figure it out you look in there
and by the time I get back to figure out
the solution you didn't just want to
stand up with me huh okay I'm gonna go
get alex alex is coming to help
apparently he brought pizza and some
beer so wait what am i doing l think
escaliers elevators stairs I don't see
Alex
what's up why didn't you hard but you're
staying right yeah yeah Oh getting that
sound grunting getting old getting oh no
need to work out more um just click it
say you're a terrorist terrorist way the
who leave a link hi I'm on uh but i'm
alex i'm visiting Evan Carmichael he
just moved in you're going ahead yeah
thank you start with some next level and
today I was gonna say terrorist I
actually was but I'm like no this for
here is it a parking front end down
there over here at the front end look at
that boom followed by a boom boom in the
cars I look at that boom is not the
sound you Jesus Christ there we go about
so I got your beer
water we're gonna be one of your
hands-free because you're not just gonna
be pretty busy staring since Oakes I
have one of my hands-free yeah give you
the bag my pointer my head but I gotta
hold the key so you have the key in one
hand and Cameron one I'm grabbed oh we
don't need the water yet we have I
bought water a little bit Nina's like we
can't wait an hour for Alex oh this is
it we can't wait an hour for Alex mitch
is like and you know Alex is that gonna
be on time anyway so where's the beer
where's the pizza I go to order a pullet
mean of three times I'm like I'm going
to come over and we'll order oh so you
just have beer and water oh ok so give
me that I'll take the beer here I'll
take the beer you take the water I'm
good you have a word with me all right
I'll fill as lovely as she is I'll film
it I'll get much I appreciate her as an
assistant listen don't hate on the end
this is believed nation watching you're
gonna get torn to shreds friend they
love mean on this channel yeah he wanted
to know if you're gonna be here past
midnight I said I hope not it's actually
really nice place it over put something
in this temple you got it lookin do good
you know you're gonna get fatter it
would you consider it's a phosphate
quarters what are you serious pizza is
like the definition of fast food Donald
burning like and think like right no
please
a nice restaurant this is what you
learned from Alex here we are happens
hey yeah I brought an Armenian with me
this is an awesome space I like the red
actually this is really nice I think
maybe this this cult maybe could use a
something different though right yeah
we're not keeping the green yeah it's
not great what are you gonna do
something else but we gotta set up first
but it's good that the red is already
done and it's relatively fresh if you
look at it cuz res the one of the
hardest colors to work with actually you
need a bunch of clothes to do it ok
first impressions I love it it's a nice
space a lot of a lot of magic can happen
here you get a beautiful view window is
super important um I love the kitchen I
love the island we're gonna have some
great parties here all right if drinks
and food in here and so from alex is out
so the movers are done why is the
mattress in the living room alright
whatever well cuz you have any thought
about it we got installed the bed we got
boxes everywhere I'll show you what the
bedrooms looking like Alex's noshing on
some doughnuts good diving deep they
refuse to eat the doughnuts man okay we
got to put this together time to get to
work I love rock and roll out to doing
some biz and doing some biz uh something
else touching my phone right holy cow
hello alex is playing with knives
and then this is why you take pictures
okay are you killing my angle dude I had
it all set up dude it was a time-lapse
you don't mess with a camera while it's
doing time lapse disease Schultz you
don't have access to mm-hmm so these
shows but the Venables this way and you
want a wall here well the best this way
oh I thought this is the length of the
bed that's what I'm sure to wrap my
brain around
but it's done
you